und außerdem unser bauch liegt auch noch
irgendwie auf dem ding drauf und dann
klappt das ja gar nicht so gut bekommen
ich lass dich einfach los hier und dann
kann es ja mal alleine weitermachen
ja und jetzt gehen natürlich da zurück
das ist ein blödes level das sind
allgemein gerade blöde level one world
race to buy das hört sich doch mal geil
an
pusch wie so push me as cool wir können
es ankommt mitgliedern sterben the few
seconds of their impact
okay ganz wichtig mit rakete so
weihnachtsmann was passiert mit dir
ach so ja bei dir drehen sich die sache
das ist klar bei dir schickt sich das
zusammen oder aha da ist einfach was
reingefallen ja bei dir die kettensäge
my favorite was haben wir hier ja leser
oder
eine rakete das ist doch wie den
vibrator eigentlich und deswegen jetzt
auch auf wave second ok weiter auch ein
[ __ ] ein farbiger denke ich auch eine
rakete aber im bauch und du wirst aua
aua das tut doch bestimmt auch weh so
ich dachte wird jetzt auf gewalt einfach
wait for big boss möchte gar nicht zu
[Musik]
ach so der dass das limit erreicht weil
sie nicht irgendwie jedenfalls deswegen
konnten das nicht 100 werden woran also
wahrscheinlich kriegen wir ziemlich
viele pfeile abgeschossen
italien erhält hilfe ich bin voll mit
488 ehec sich sehr schön sehr schön sehr
schön station remakes und mein gott oh
mein gott oh mein gott kriegsschiff zu
beginnen der hattrick nicht okay
ja wo ist unser kleiner sohn oro ich
sollte mich vielleicht festhalten
restart diesmal nehme ich dich mit ich
glaube hängen wir gerade wie was das ist
mal komisch dadurch drücken wir immer
eben schiff dann fällig sondern unser
kleiner sohn auch der kleine sondern
auch um mein gott oh mein gott die fette
kuh liegt auf uns drauf die hält unseren
helm fest ja ich weiß ja safety first
und so aber das ist trotzdem nie und wie
können wir das überhaupt schaffen
ach des bundes tod der mit
ich krieg pfeile die fresse okay wie
können wir das denn jetzt überleben
wir können also ein bisschen wackeln
jetzt wie auf dem rummelplatz
ja das zum thema wie auf dem rummelplatz
egal so kessel escape also raus aus der
ihm aus dem aus der burg entflieht
letzteres könnte sich das wieder
schaffen ja vertraut wir nehmen einfach
ein paar leute okay es ist echt komisch
das ist immer so stand bilder von ihm
sind
ich hätte es auch komisch dass manche
leute kann man einfach umfahren und
andere nicht juli tritt rating what
happens next ja das habe ich bewertet
mein gott was blödes level one face to
the top von der lampe erschlagend balkon
die so willkommen kühlschrank gas
ja ja das war's
ich glaube solche levels ist einfach
nicht dazu da um den spieler zu fordern
sondern einfach nur zu behalten
stehen geblieben
okay gut access to many was wir so ich
mir letztes noch ein teil von angeguckt
ich weiß nicht mehr welche ok klicken
ich glaube das müsste wenn ich auch
relativ leicht schaffen
[Musik]
das kann auch nicht allzu schwer sein
kann noch nicht allzu schwer sein
nein aber mir ist aufgefallen dass wir
eigentlich einen anderen weg hätten
nehmen müssen
so jetzt einfach noch mal
eigentlich muss man wirklich immer nur
geradeaus fahren drive fest so sein ding
getötet guck ich meinte dass nämlich
dass wir jetzt das so umhauen
dann gucken wir ihnen hier einen video
von ja sehr schön
genauso war es glaube ich auch gedacht
so weiter geht so weiter geht's weiter
geht's okay
weiter geht es dann wir irgendwie
getötet werden
you can save ist ja jay ist nein ich
hasse ihn nicht ich bringe einfach um
aber ich nehme seinen fuß mit und
verliere meinen so du stirbst noch und
ihr beiden städten wird los wir müssen
irgendwie zurück jordan oder wie auch
immer ich genannt habe
peter jordan ach ich bin wirklich noch
menschen umbringen nein nein wir wir
schaffen das jetzt nicht mit unseren
auch löhne
das kann doch nicht sein
sehr schön die travel hates chris noth
kind raid 5
ich nehme mal epic erotik haben bisher
laut to fly
das hat sich doch gut an
ok
es ist gerade irgendwie so als wenn der
weiß ich nicht begreift wer oder so ich
könne fliehen
ach so wie jetzt drehen wir uns gut test
und perfect obstacle
ich kann nicht mehr steuern gehört der
87 ich mache gerade gar nichts mehr
renault lässt es
jetzt wahrscheinlich du musst ins team
gekommen doch wahrscheinlich unser kopf
einfach droht ist egal wir haben es ja
geschafft gewissermaßen ich habe gar
nichts gemacht und das war gut
superman weshalb uns superman jetzt
erhält in einer welt der dritte sehr
schön habe es geschafft innerhalb von
neun sekunden
da sind wir gut da und lukas fußball
eigentlich heißt es ja football league
soccer
aber egal sehr schön aber da war auf
jeden fall schon mal das ziel von daher
kennt wie kann man endlich zu sich vom
kind wechseln das war ja auch mal ganz
interessant wenn man uns zu wissen würde
könnt ihr mir das mal bitte in die
kommentare schreiben dass wir nicht
folge häufig gar nicht so sich des
kindes wechsel dass ich quasi das kind
sähe die anderes level und nochmal zu
holen ist damit der mensch nicht schon
wieder so holt steuerung kvg weiter geht
s weiter geht's
das pretty girls get me you anything but
if you wish to continue heftige debatten
ach so jetzt bin ich auch schon fast tot
so weiter blablabla
oh ich glaube dass
ja sehr schön sehr schön gar nicht
klappt wir können ja dann mal happy
wales quiz das ist ja auch interessant
blablabla so hierdurch sehr schön
weitergeht epic jambo mein gott wie epic
games steht das nicht eben auf der seite
steht ihr gar nicht ich sag mal das ist
gar nicht schwer ich kann mich ja mit
dem spiel gar nicht aus ich doch mal ich
glaube dass es falsch ist und ja es war
falsch
dann war es der zweite nämlich die hier
sehr schön
what we first vehicle kurz los ach mist
war es war
ich glaube das war doch auf titelkurs
oder oder nicht
die hier 100 prozentig für detail gucke
ich selber hätte ich jetzt auch die
craften dass sie kaputt machen
next skyrim minecraft minecraft
minecraft
[Musik]
was können wir sollten nächstes machen
wir können wir obst spielen playnow das
ist de support ja ich muss wieder
festhalten ich habe mir noch
festgehalten arsch so japaner nein raus
so pasta und glas braker ach jetzt kann
ich wieder einen aussuchen kann man die
wieder die beiden turteltäubchen nehmen
macspeech ich sterbe gleich auch das
macht nichts ich habe glas inhalt keiner
so jetzt cool wenn ich auf die sicht vom
sohn wechseln könnte wenn ich zum
beispiel an karriere wir schaffen das
einfach mit dem kopf durch die wand das
ist immer die beste möglich so merkt er
dass für das leben und natürlich das ist
alles möglich und wir schaffen das auch
schon richtig unmöglich einfach immer
gegen vallendar ist es genau das
richtige level für mich ich will auch
mal kaputt machen okay
facebook so du bist so blöd ich vergebe
nichts ich verbrechen ich wir sind viele
hart so und weißt du was noch alles drin
weiter geht's los war schloss mein gott
das ist nur schwer gehabt so in seen und
das müssen wir jetzt eigentlich mal
schaffen weil das war ja vorher nur so
weil der sohn wollte das unbedingt nein
gar nicht
der sohn wollte das unbedingt
kaputtmachen von daher haben wir das
dann nicht so ganz geschafft wie ich das
wollte
so jetzt fallen auch hier drüber man
auch alter als darf doch nicht wahr sein
so das letzte mal dass ich jetzt dieses
level hier versuche somit die uno club
karton wie norman nicht sonderlich
schwer hat brauchen wir damit schon die
ersten das erste mal zwei versuche wir
könnten theoretisch auch jetzt schon
wieder fahren halt die fresse kann ich
nicht gleich unser kind los nein ich
hätte dich nicht du hast alles versaut
[Musik]
das ist den fuß naja ich glaube da
braucht man den kopf müssen wir ja
shoppen gehen almost impossible ok und
zack und im pokal gegen gebrettert
und es darf doch nicht wahr sein egal
leute das war es erstmal wieder für
dieses mal happy meals mittels dann in
der nächsten folge ja [ __ ] euch alle